congress hasn't passed more
comprehensive stimulus legislation since
the cares act in march
and many of the protections that came
with it have been scaled back or
expired so what's holding up the
legislation
the holdup with stimulus is the same
disagreement that has been there
since march essentially and it boils
down to
republicans kind of under the leadership
of senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell want
a smaller package they want it to be
targeted they don't want
any provisions that they see as kind of
unrelated to the coronavirus pandemic to
be in the bill
their most recent offer was somewhere
around the 500 billion
range and then on the other side of the
spectrum you have democrats led by nancy
pelosi who are pushing for
a big package you know multi-trillion
dollars
her most recent offer was worth about
2.2 trillion and that's more than a
trillion
smaller than her original offer so she
wants a big piece of sweeping
legislation and says i'm not going to
budge on that and republicans say well
we're not going to vote for anything
that's
you know bigger than we want it to be
and so that's the impasse and they
haven't been able to get
around it yet there's more than just
money holding up the negotiations
democrats republicans and the white
house remain far apart on
key issues including funding for schools
federal unemployment insurance
supplements
liability protections for businesses and
state and local aid
now with mcconnell likely to take full
control of the republican reigns on
stimulus
the next bill has two paths forward
lawmakers could try to pass in the lame
duck session
while trump is still president and
democrats have a more decisive majority
in the house
or they can wait until january after
president-elect
biden is sworn in and a january runoff
election in georgia for two senate seats
has determined which party will control
that chamber
i think most folks even though you know
lawmakers are saying we want it
immediately i think most
experts are saying it's more likely that
we'll have it after january
especially because you know the senate
and house will be focused
over the next six weeks on funding the
government
there's a huge deadline coming up on
december 11th for
lawmakers to agree on the federal budget
to keep the doors open to keep the
lights on to keep federal agencies
running
and that is going to be priority number
one ahead of stimulus
over the next couple weeks and both
mcconnell and pelosi have called for a
new omnibus spending bill
not another continuing resolution that
simply keeps the government funded
temporarily
senate republicans this week released
kind of their opening offer
for that omnibus spending bill and covid
relief was not included
in it democrats were immediately you
know up in arms about the lack of money
for
coronavirus in there so that kind of
remains to be
seen i think it's i think it's too early
to speculate on
you know where those negotiations are
going to go